hey everyone how's it going so it is
summer it which means that school is out
which means that some of y'all are
headed to your first full-time job oh my
god did I hear someone's got a new job
oh hey Masha it's not me by the way a
bunch of people just graduated and
they're about to embark on their careers
with their first job out of college oh
my god it's so exciting and hello
everybody my name is Masha I'm the
blonde from coding blonde and my channel
and my blog are all about technology and
especially focusing on women in tech I
was just supposed to tell everybody some
tips and advice for their first job
would you like to help me out yes I
would love to let's get started all
right so the first piece of advice is
that your first job out of college
doesn't have to be perfect the whole
point of getting a job straight out of
college well apart from you know making
money and a lot of stuff the whole point
of it is to try different things to get
your hands dirty and to understand what
things you like and want things you
don't like
sometimes understanding what you don't
like it's almost more important than
understanding what you do like because
those things might change but you really
dislike some job or profession or
activity that is good information to
know so it doesn't have to be perfect
you need to get your hands dirty
first secondly this is your time to
build up skills transferable skills that
will then take you to the next level my
dad always said at first you're working
towards your city or you're working for
your CV and after that your CV starts
working for you this is when you're
working for your CV and you're working
for your skill set you need to have
something so that you can sell yourself
better and so that you can sell your
unique skills your unique experience
much better later thirdly on the same
point you can always change your career
down the line the thing is it doesn't
have to be a direct path it doesn't have
to be a straight line you can do
different things and
different things and I'm a huge believer
in diagonal growth versus just vertical
this way you are trying different things
and expanding your knowledge we live in
the society now we're changing careers
or changing trajectories is a completely
normal thing so the next step that I
have is to ask lots of questions when I
started my first job impostor syndrome
definitely got to the best of me and so
I thought things like I don't deserve to
be here or what if they find out that I
don't actually know anything if you
think about it
companies chose to hire you and they
want you to be the best employee that
you can be one of the best ways to
become a great employee is honestly to
learn a lot I'm sure you could kind of
just like hang out and stuff but I think
the best way to learn is to engage and
ask lots of questions and be part of the
conversation it also looks like if you
get stuck on something for a long time
then asking for help I don't think that
asking for help is a sign of weakness at
all it's actually a sign of strength it
means that you yourself know that you
don't know how to fix this problem and
admitting that and being vulnerable with
others and asking others for help so
that you both can get the job done I
know that's rather like very stubborn
when I started my job and there's a lot
of pride and ego that I had to work
through too so if that's the case
honestly it's not worth it and also I
think the best companies and best teams
want to learn from others and get fresh
perspectives on what they're currently
doing so questioning why things the way
that they are actually is a very great
way to challenge the current assumptions
and that honestly makes for a better
team and a better product so yeah like
ask lots of questions I think it is one
of the best ways to be successful at
your new job oh I have one that's along
the same lines see everything as an
opportunity you will face obstacles
along the way for sure whether it's in
your direct job or whether it's in your
extracurricular activities or projects
anything there will be obstacles the
whole point here is that you need to
change your perspective of these
obstacles from something that's
preventing you to achieve X to something
that will teach you a skill so see
everything as an opportunity to learn a
new skill let's say the best example
here is actually well programming when
your encounter bugs they either get you
super frustrated or they teach you
something and it just depends on your
perspective of things if you see them as
learning opportunities you'll be a
happier and B you will learn something
you will learn more than if you just
bang your head against the wall in fact
in that case you could have just like
you know eliminated some brain cells
the point is see everything as an
opportunity to learn to develop a new
skills everything is these skills and
new learnings are the ones that will
take you to the next level they're going
to differentiate your skillset and make
you you and make you unique I love this
example I always use this so if you've
seen some of my videos around career
before you will recognize it but I will
use it again the door metaphor I like to
think of a career or of any
opportunities as door opening so when
you graduate from college you have a
different set of doors in front of you
let's say you have just graduated with
computer science degree so the different
paths that you have are to go into to
become a software engineer or data
analyst or do you understand what I mean
these are the different professions you
could pick if you did communications or
marketing you know like you have a set
of professions that will be open for you
the doors will be open for you so
depending on your interest you can
select one or the other
everybody's doors are unique and so you
will decide on a door that interests you
the most and when you go through it
depending on what projects you are
working on what people your amazing it
will open another set of doors that you
know I like to multiply my doors I like
to make sure that once I will cram
through a door I have more doors opening
to me off to that so it's all about this
it's all about building your skills and
creating more opportunities for you okay
cool so now that you are a capital a
adult now I think it's really important
for you to take the time to get to know
yourself you've probably learned a lot
about yourself through high school in
college but you also have this
completely new part of your life that
you're embarking on and the person who's
going to lead that journey is you no one
else so I think it's always important to
ask yourself who you are what your
values are and what's important to you
especially at this time in your life and
like one great way of doing this is
honestly to try a bunch of stuff be
open-minded take every opportunity you
have because sure some of those things
you're gonna fail and some of those
things aren't going to work out but at
the end of the day you're going to learn
something about yourself or learn about
the world and I think that's a net
positive so I'm gonna continue mascha
store analogy so pretend that now you
have all these doors open but you have
to figure out which one is the best door
to choose and I think knowing yourself
and what's important to you and what
your values are is going to help you
make the right decisions choose the
right door and I know that sometimes
this can be really scary because it can
mean confronting your fears your doing
something that you're not super
comfortable with and one of the things
that I learned in the last couple of
years is to really learn how to embrace
that fear because doing so is going to
help you push a little bit out of your
comfort zone each time so that you're
always stretching yourself oh I know
that's so well vaseline fear has become
my hobby at this point I know it's
pretty brave to say that but in any case
my biggest leap up to date was when I
moved from my role at Google back in
November it was very scary I moved to a
different country and started a new job
and a completely different feel like you
know diagonally 100% diagonally and also
you know personal life changes moved in
with my boyfriend very scary stuff but
it has paid off it really has paid off
so you have to embrace that fear and
lastly maybe you're actually doing this
already but I think this is a really
great time to find your community I say
this because a lot of those things are
honestly hard to do alone like when you
hit a wall or you fail really hard then
having people there to support you and
pick you back up is going to be really
really important and so while a lot of
people talk about this in a professional
sense
like having frequent one-on-ones with
your managers to continually get
feedback from them about what you can be
doing and having them support you in
your career I also think it's just as
important to surround yourself with
people that you feel comfortable with
who can support you when times are
really hard so whether that be friends
or college friends or neighbors so find
people to share perspective with and get
advice from because that can be really
helpful and they can support you when
you're down and you can also do that for
them too
oh hey that's kind of what we're doing
right now supporting each other and
collaborating to make some content
together yeah you know what you're right
the Internet's an amazing place okay so
one last thing that you want to leave
you with as Food for Thought people will
always ask you what do you want to do in
life where do you see yourself in five
years and what's important to you which
is scary but if you take the time to
think about all the things that we
talked about then it actually makes it a
lot easier to answer those questions
that's right
this serves as the foundation for the
roadmap for you for the next year or a
few years you'll be able to figure out
what you'd like to achieve where you'd
like to take your career and what
opportunities to face as well as how to
make tough decisions and the thing is
once you're on that roadmap still keep
an eye out for exciting opportunities
because like I said you can always go
diagonally and work towards achieving
your new goals and if you have a great
community of people around you they can
help you in achieving those that's right
well awesome honestly I don't think we
have anything left to say except good
luck you're going to do great and thanks
wash up for being on my channel and
helping me out with this no problem
thank you so much for having me now if
you're still in the job hunting phase
then let's head on over to marshes
channel where we talk about technical
interviewing tips by clicking right here
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and leave a comment down below
with your advice for new grads during
their first jobs don't forget to
subscribe to my channel and coding
blonde Masha has a lot of great content
about tech and so I highly recommend you
go check her out cool so I'm gonna head
on over to her channel now so I'll see
you there bye